the cdc says the daily covet cases have
reached the highest
total since february before most
americans could be vaccinated
the number of new cases topped 106 000
yesterday
this year's massive sturgis motorcycle
rally starts today
and many doctors are worried it could
become a super spreader event
more than half a million people are
expected to pour into the small south
dakota town for the 10-day festival
mololenki is in sturgis at the corner of
main street and harley-davidson way mola
good morning
well good morning dana later today main
street here will just be a sea
of motorcycles you know bikers look
forward to this rally all year long but
this year it comes at a time
when the delta variant is ripping
through this country here in south
dakota the vaccination rate
is right around the national average and
on the rise but
also on the rise new coveted cases
health officials say just last week
they saw a nearly 70 percent jump
[Music]
bikers from nearly every state are
expected to pack the streets of sturgis
for what organizers believe
will be one of their biggest rallies in
the event's 81 year history
what's different about this year if
anything different
people want to get out i think it's just
the lock up last year
people want to escape and they're
escaping the south dakota
but there are concerns some rally goers
could bring home more than just a
souvenir
just last month in wisconsin tens of
thousands of milwaukee bucks fans
celebrated the team's nba championship
health officials say nearly
500 people ended up getting coveted this
could be
a super spreader we don't want it to be
but that's the reality
dr shankarkura says it's already the
busiest week for his hospital in rapid
city
because of the number of trauma cases
related to the rally the highly
contagious delta variant
poses an additional challenge what have
you done to get to this point the entire
team stays in place no one takes
vacation and we also recruit more folks
in anticipation of any increase in cases
for local business owners like rod
bradley the event provides a huge
economic impact
long after the bikers are gone he
welcomes the crowds
as long as they take some personal
responsibility obviously you know
my 70 some year old mom isn't coming
downtown right and so
protect the vulnerable and take
responsibility for yourself so
yeah it's definitely a theme in sturgeon
at the rally but it's also been a theme
of south dakota since
the virus hit
during this rally there will be no mass
mandates no vaccination mandates but
there will be sanitation stations set up
at various points throughout town and
this year for the first time ever
open container open alcohol containers
will be allowed outside
as the city tries to encourage people to
come outside from the bars
and be outside in the open air where of
course vlad we know health officials say
the virus is less likely to spread all
right mola thank you very much
appreciate it